hey guys my name's Jess I'm here with
Tam and we're super excited we've got
you guys back this year and Philip you
came while she with lego dimensions and
it was a lovely interview so I'm glad
you're back with a Lego Marvel Super
Heroes - all right so set us up we got a
new area we're in Cronulla so we got a
new bad guy yeah we have a new bad guy
who's probably I would say my favorite
Marvel villain well he's quite
villainous he's a niche character as
well I shout out to you guys of the of
the books amazing work he is just a
great character because he is you know
I'm not gonna go too deep into he's from
the 40th century he has all this amazing
technology he can time travel but he's
he's like a really noble general and he
doesn't just he's not gonna just rock up
and just vaporize people he wants to
come and and fight the best of the best
in their prime and defeat them
toe-to-toe so he's like just such a
great character yeah so for us the time
travel means we can kind of go anywhere
and do anything and then also the fact
that he has all this cool technology and
gadgets you can bring in you know and
this is where the game is about time you
can bring in characters and realities
from everywhere yep probably major
villain is yeah yeah so you know Kang
the concrete is you know he just he's
such an amazing year bad guy and the
story did the original story kind of
weaves this this track of how he turns
up how he forms this open-world city of
kanopolis from all these different
realities from out of time and then
eventually this journey and this faceoff
with him in in a like an epic showdown
which is it's all comic-book inspired as
well it's yeah the Heritage is back in
two runs avengers forever and also the
kang dynasty which was kind of avengers
yeah i feel it's very important we
reference we do have a demo you guys
have want a demo for us that you guys
are watching right now so what are we
looking at it it's all very intense
so this is right at the start of the
game before yeah this is just as Kang
turns up yeah we've got the Guardians
they've been called out to Xander
there's an emergency they turn up and it
just so happens Kang's they're going
right I'm gonna have a
pieces and our four kanopolis brings in
this huge guy who's east on the searcher
he's a celestial from the ends of time
right so it's all very dramatic but the
reason we start like the hot with the
guardians is the first game like a
marvel see there's one from 2013 and we
ended with this tease right at the end
of the game where we were set it up with
the guardians turned up at earth speak
to Nick Fury that just saved the earth
and the Guardians like well we're not
actually here for that we yes some other
reason and then said raisin exactly and
so for us it's great we've like said the
story is an original branching story so
you don't have to have played the first
one
but if you have you're gonna be like
right okay this all makes sense yeah you
guys kind of know what they do it as
always you've got a huge cost of
characters Marvel heroes from across
continuities and timelines but this time
you've tried to kind of make everyone
feel a bit more distinct and introduce
unique aspects of his character like
when I saw this game previously you had
a an excellent reference to the
Guardians movie in the Peter quill
character so can you talk a little bit
about that yeah it's it's one of those
things when we look at each character we
try and distill them down so what is it
about their personality that makes them
cool and exciting and quirky and you
know we'll reference you know movies
cartoons comic books to try and you know
extract the best bits what those
character is gonna do so you know once
feels kind of deactivated Isan here
we'll see exactly what star-lord can do
he's like you say with with his
abilities he can he can basically listen
to his mixtape which is super awesome
and the same with you know you with
Gamora with group with rocket and then
with the whole other they they are all
kind of coming to life with that
personality you know this little tiny
group but the great thing is he has
found a little bit of khang technology
which it allows him to go backwards and
forward in time to grow yeah so you can
even just do it by time-travel you've
actually picked up on a number of rather
interesting iterations of your
characters you've got future Spidey
right and you've got cowboy Captain
America how is the decision behind
incorporating those it kind of highlight
the breath of of where we're going yeah
we can go and pick characters from the
Wild West like say like cowboy cap if we
can go forward to 2099 versions of
characters and everywhere in between you
know we the amount of research we've
been doing yeah we've even got some
medieval like Marvel heroes and villains
which is like that's that's super cool
did you know that there was Egyptian
Avengers you know that there's such a
cool like mix of characters out there
and I think that is that's what makes
the story exciting when you can have
three different versions of you know
spider-man character yeah kind of meet
each other and they're all kind of like
what's going on here is you know I go by
they're not you and yeah it makes for
some real good humor in the same year
when you've got a couple of versions of
Captain America bumping into each other
but yeah I think through the story
there's yeah there's 35 characters that
drop in and drop that does carry me on
to my next question I mean I had read
that you said there was more than 30
characters woven into the story at
different points how do you handle that
from a narrative perspective when you're
telling a story you just have so many
drop in and drop out exactly cuz it's
got to make sense yes yeah you've got
you've got the whole time thing which is
gonna be a bit confusing though the huge
roster of characters what we do is we
kind of ground it back we we start after
level one with Avengers mansion and
we've got wasp in there who's just kind
of holding the for directing you know
the Avengers making sure everyone knows
what's going on so we keep going back
there to ensure that the player is
reminded of where they are and what's up
what's occurring so her and giant man
back Avengers HQ which just so happens
to get ripped out and put into crop
lists as well yeah kind of ties it all
together so here we go his today right
and yeah it's one of those things that
the bad guys have just all stop and
dance and it kind of just takes the
sting out like big bow epic action
scenes but every character has something
cool and exciting yeah we've got team-up
move see you know you can team up
star-lord onto yeah
grew shoulders and just lots of
excitement because you know our games a
fun quirky whimsical authentic and we
just want people to have fun with it
yeah of course you have also said you've
changed to combat quite a bit this time
around him yeah can you explain how yeah
it's it's one of those things we yeah
the first game was really popular and
was really well-received so yeah we
looked at that and thought you know what
for a sequel you kind of have to make
sure everything is improved right so for
combat we've we've put a load of stuff
in there that effectively means even
though we're still making it accessible
you know simple inputs yeah you can pull
off special moves team up moves there
are enemies in there that they're not
just pop boilers that are just gonna
fill a room and slow you down you know
you're gonna have to actively think
about how you get past them you know the
armored guys how do I get rid of the
armor you know guys that are gonna react
in different ways we've got guys that
actually go invisible and some of your
stealth goons around you it's like right
how do I get about those so we really
try to just push the bar just have a lot
of fun with it I guess we'll make it
this game has to be bigger and better
otherwise you bringing in you talk about
all the heroes that you've got how are
you bringing in villains from across the
universe is that something that you're
looking into yeah let's see villains is
a cool thing because we've we've kind of
not touched on that one we've been
talking about the game so far
but when Kang turns up to earth his is
his whole thing and he turns up and he
just basically says listen you will
either you know follow me or if you
don't I'll crush you and so if you rise
up and follow me then I will divide
kanopolis up and you can be my generals
so at that point all the villains are
like well you know what yeah okay I'll
have a piece of the pie and then so
they're all you know you're coming up
and so as you weave through your story
to go and actually defeat khang you were
bumping into some you know awesome
villains and these villains are all
again from out of time from out of you
know different places and a lot of kind
of unexpected twists in there as well
so in the first game the earth was in
trouble we had to save the earth this
game it's the entire Marvel Universe it
is it's the entire Marvel Universe all
reality
Phil right just wants to take down
everything so I have to ask what are you
gonna do with three yeah I don't know
accelerate forward in time or go back in
time and put a kang and changing broader
question it feels like like I was kind
of undergoing a sort of Renaissance at
the moment I actually just caught like a
Batman on the plane and was pleasantly
surprised pretty good maybe you guys
like Batman I love the great partners
yeah I mean obviously you guys are huge
part of that like how does it feel to be
I mean I was playing with Lego when I
was 43 years old how does it feel to be
a part of this like huge everyone's
embracing Lego again from all ages
genders it's exciting um I think I don't
know what maybe it was the lego movie
that kind of twisted it a little bit
further into like it became super super
cool yeah we've always thought it was
cool but it was that I think when lego
movie came out it was that popular and
successful and it was like this is this
is really cool yeah and I think it's
just snowballing and snowballing we've
always been there supporting it and
we've noticed that the more and more
sort of s that we put in the more and
more our audience is kind of widened
yeah it's not just kids that play our
games yeah absolutely and I mean I think
the fact that you obviously put so much
love into like really getting these old
school references in there sacani it's
kind of like those family movies that
have references for the adults or watch
it and the fact that you're expanding
combat for the older audience I mean it
must be very hard to incorporate that
many demographics but it seems to appeal
to like Lego it's that strange thing
about it right from the very first like
a game is about making games not just it
wasn't about making kids games things we
want to play to everyone is that whole
maybe make the game as a fan of whatever
it is yeah luckily you know we're all
massive fans of absalom at ur what it is
if you think like a fan and you know
you know what it is that that makes that
property amazing yeah you'll find that
what you make becomes great and fun and
amazing and the people that love it they
love the game yeah that's great fun
making it as well absolutely we don't
have fun making it and yes it's not
gonna be a fun game but we do really
love making Lego games right Oh
completely I we love Lego and it's not
almost weird you know walking up to
someone I am just running out so we're
currently spider-man noir and we are
going to go into kanopolis so this is a
little bit of the open-world why this
game is gonna feel so different oh wow
great yes we've got this is like
Manhattan but it's all frosted over and
I see in that the reason is that as
Kang's ripped Manhattan out of time he's
also ripped Kunlun out of time and the
Finland Mountains right next to each
other and so they've the kind of snow
and ice has spilled over this kind of
green refractive edge on the sides that
is actually a Kang force field because
he has these chrono sling talking
technical now Crona pylons that like
these time pylons that cut places out of
time and put them in but very early in
the game you do something that breaks
all of that and then the whole thing
just just widens and opens if are you
able to bring the map up Phil just to
give a an idea of what we're playing
with so you've got all of these
different areas obviously we're trying
to make it look like a comic book as
well so as you're looking at the map but
this live map allows you to drop in and
pull out and you know ancient Egypt is
sat right next to ya Hydra Empire and
it's just really cool and even up in the
air you've got sort of a ttle on you've
got nowhere Guardians and Wow oh this
huge expensive map if you then just drop
back in Phil you know you're just this
like little tiny mini yet underwater
there's just there's so much stuff in
here and you know obviously you know
we've got until you know November the
games out so yeah we're currently
working on just filling this with like
crazy characters and question gameplay
and like all sorts of things that people
will not be
spectres go through the open world is it
safe to assume that if it's got Conlan
and a Dylan but the associated
characters will be there's always iron
fist in this is you could you could draw
those conclusions that might be no sweet
scoops for us were the minute we just we
revealed like lockjaw or the other day
yes he's just super cool character and
love lockjaw and then never alone though
so he's gotta have a part she is front
and center in there's no cool story like
heard we the core group are like her she
holds like Panther like I say there's
like thirty but they kind of weave in
and out yeah yeah anytime you can weave
you know kirby's Wild West Captain
America into a story yeah so yeah and
again ancient Egypt brings some pretty
cool old-time characters into into the
game see it's just fun it's really
really good fun incredible well before I
let you go I do need to ask you both who
your favorite characters are oh go on
Phil you go so I'm a sucker for
something that I saw the team do uh-huh
when they added Groot and baby Groot yes
running around a baby grew I just do
this for hours I'm really bad at the
office that my I just run around corn
office just as bad boo not doing
anything just rat around so he's
carrying my favorite yeah for me it's
any Hulk related character yeah I in the
new Hulk which I also have a t-shirt The
Hulk that's gonna obviously appear in
thor ragnarok which that looked amazing
yeah seeing Hulk with all the armor on
you know the knowing where that goes the
whole planet whole it's a car and and
everything I'm just thinking yet yeah
hopes a great car absolutely and finally
has you told to play this one yet Lily
she has a good he's a sucker for Groot
as well by choice T truth
oh yeah that's fantastic I'm so glad you
guys could come down and bring the game
it's awesome to get another look at it
thank you so much and I hope you guys
have a great rest of show and when does
the game coming out when can we get it
where can we get it November the 14th is
out in North America November the 17th
back home and the rest of the world you
can pre-order it now and I believe
there's a classic guardians are the
galaxy pack or something if you if you
preorder early
so that's but this is like prior to
guardians game but this is old-school
so yeah there's some good stuff but yes
we order it now great there you go you
heard the man alrighty thanks so much
guys we will be back in just a moment
with southpark the fractured butthole
[Laughter]